foreign
Justin's with us in Colorado Springs hey
Justin welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave hey Jay my two favorite hosts
how are you better than we deserve how
can we help
yes I'm sure you guys don't remember me
but I called in about a month ago and I
thought it was going to be a bad YouTube
segment didn't end up being too bad oh
yeah I think I remember tell me more
yeah so uh we uh we had the only debt we
had was a you know a truck and
um I was had some questions about
investing long term and you guys laid
out a really good plan for me and I'm
kind of here just to give you a little
update
cool wanna hear it yeah so I didn't
follow your plan to a T and hence why
I'm calling
and so we uh we had a third and we had
about I thought we had about a thirty
thousand dollars uh truck room we
actually had about 37 but you guys
recommended we pull it from our savings
and pay it off and we didn't pay it off
that day but we did pay it off on in
three weeks so 37 000 in three weeks so
I wanted to let you know it was a very
successful call we followed you guys as
tips and now we are officially debt free
and uh yes and with that um I did quick
math on it at the 650 monthly
contributions we were doing
um on our truck and insurance
um on a rate of return of 10 average
after 20 years that's 500 000 and 30
years that's over one million wonderful
yeah so and my question today and I once
again I hope you guys take it easy on me
with this we did free up the cash and we
did Max out the 15
of our uh 401ks and we do have an extra
good chunk of money going to the house
and do you have your uh three to six
months emergency fund
in the last show that uh Dave you
recommended I follow up on my 529 it is
in a mutual account and there's
currently fifteen thousand dollars in
there okay good good and um and now my
question is we I do have a little bit
more freedom money and I know I know I
think the answer to this I used to
dabble a little bit in the day trading
should I play around with that or just
leave it alone
you uh you know the answer you know the
answer to that I mean okay the stud the
studies tell us 78 of the day Traders
lose money
okay so it's not as bad as buying a
lottery ticket but it's close
okay
yeah I uh about years ago when I was
actually worked in the financial
industry I used to do a little trading
and I did okay but I know the market is
a little bit different today you know
the other study that's very interesting
on day trading is this day Traders are a
lot like fishermen
they remember the days they caught stuff
and they have a mental block on the days
they didn't
okay yeah and they go yeah the fishing's
pretty good over there you usually catch
something and you really don't but you
just remember the days you caught fish
you know and so it actually is weird you
you probably didn't but you block it out
because it's like this is fun and I'm
good at it and no you're really not
you're suck and so don't do it you know
and I I don't do it and I know a lot
about it I don't fool with it uh I would
rather you get your house paid off and
if you want to trade in something save
up a pile of money and buy you a piece
of Real Estate
okay you got a lot better chance of
making some money
uh buying a piece of real estate selling
it you know that kind of stuff then you
do with cash no debt than you do after
your house is paid off then you do
messing around day trading but
um I mean day trading is
it's just again I I don't care what
people do you can do whatever you want
to do yeah but what I'm always looking
for for me and I'm not going to tell you
guys to do something out there that I
wouldn't do personally yeah I'm looking
for something that has a high
probability of success and so I don't
really care what your broke
brother-in-law's opinion is
and so that's why I didn't buy crypto
and now I look like a freaking genius
and I didn't buy Bernie Madoff and now I
look like a freaking genius you know and
I didn't uh and you know I don't try to
make my money at the craps table in
Vegas and now I look like a freaking
genius and I don't buy lottery tickets
and now I look like a freaking genius
and so all I do is figure whatever broke
people are doing and their suggestions
are I tried to not do that and then you
look like a freaking genius you know and
so uh that's how this thing works and
then you find out what rich people are
doing and you know the number of
millionaires that we studied out of 10
167 that made their million dollars or
greater net worth that we studied in
doing day trading
precisely zero
about as many as made it using airline
miles with their credit card yeah wealth
gained hastily will dwindle
we know that and my guy you know if
you're if you're chasing after that
chances are you're trying to get rich
quick I mean let's just say it like that
that's a good point here's the thing you
got to remember okay there's gambling
I'm making fun of it yeah there's
gambling and that's real gambling okay
that's like we're playing cards we're
playing the roulette wheel we're playing
craps okay real game are betting on a
sports team whatever that's real
gambling all right then there is
speculating which is where I'm trying to
make a short term
gain and it's usually a high gain right
and then there's investing and investing
is always over a long period of time
investing is always the tortoise
where speculating is the hair
and I don't know gambling your drunk
brother-in-law I don't know whatever it
is I don't know but it's um but you know
what I'm saying tortoise the tortoises
who we find when we study wealthy people
we always find tortoises yeah I'm fine
with being a tortoise you know anytime
I've ever posted about this you know
about your rate of return and this and
that and people are always saying Jade
you can't get a 10 rate of return where
can I find that and I realize you're not
500 you're not alone but they're not
long-term thinkers because they're
thinking how can I get a 10 return this
year or right now or this week this week
and I'm like that's not how it works
you've got to be invested over time
you've got to be in this thing for the
Long Haul it's it's a habit and a muscle
that you're building over time allowing
that compound interest to grow for you
so yeah you know what different mindset
it's just
I'm the guy that always I wanted I
always thought I was smarter than the
average bear and I could figure it out
and I could find a way to do the
shortcut yeah and my wife every time I
bring it up something even sounds like
that she goes you're scheming and
scamming
yeah you're scheming and scamming you're
trying to hide the P under a shell just
do the SMART stuff quit trying to be
quit trying to beat the system yeah you
know it's like well I mean that you're
the one the ones that always I love if
you read our comments people ripping on
us yeah it's like well Ramsay's advice
is good if you want to be middle class
except for those millions of
millionaires that we made but other than
that yeah that's so funny because
because this is somebody who's trying to
speculate yeah and get rich quick and
get rich easy and it best way to get
rich quick is get rich slow well and
everybody thinks that they've come up
with a new new and improved way yeah
right there's theirs is the new Surefire
way yeah I mean like nothing down real
estate's new it's like it's blown up
like it's never happened before because
it's on Tic Tac that's what made it that
way it's not it's new it's not new I was
doing nothing down real estate in 1982
before you or any of you out there were
a sparkle in your mama's eye I mean
seriously unbelievable
wow it's not new there's there's just
new versions of stupid that's right new
versions
there's nothing new Under the Sun wow
still stupid stuff good question sir
thanks for following up